the legacy of storytelling in the
african-american black community is rich
in its historic this morning in
recognition of Black History Month we
hear from leading voices about the
impact of stories through history as
well as their personal experiences that
inspire them
they include civil rights icon and
Congressman John Lewis writer and
director D Reese actor Jesse Williams
writer Jacqueline Woodson writer Jason
Reynolds and actress and dancer Debbie
Allen I think the first time I realized
I was black and that it meant something
was hearing James Brown say say it loud
I'm black and I'm proud and it was like
wow yeah we can't say this I am proud it
was a moment of realizing that black was
beautiful and having come from the south
and coming from a Jim Crow South into
that moment
it was everything I saw a sign that said
white men colored men white women
colored women my skin is black I knew
that I was different we have to tell the
story we have to make it plain
[Music]
so people can feel it so people can be
inspired
[Music]
they were always barriers and you know
glass ceilings and wooden and iron doors
to get through you can't get caught up
in the the madness of hate and anger you
won't get there the creative spirit has
to live in a place of joy and light not
darkness think about the fact that I get
to be a writer born born from a lineage
of people who are not supposed to read
like how could I not be overcome with
joy and overcome with with with with
pride was illegal for us to read and
write in this country for for quite a
while for for centuries in fact and
punishable by death and far worse so we
had to be creative and figure out ways
to communicate and survive and if you're
lucky thrive and have moments of you
know fleeting joy and and and pleasure
and expression it is part of the
tradition coming all the way back from
Africa the griot was the one that kept
the history the storytellers with that
story telling the civil rights movement
would have been like a bird without
wings we understood it because we were
seeing black men lynched and hung from
trees and people water hose down when
dogs and for a young person that kind of
violence coming to you from the
authority that was terrorism the civil
rights movement was powerful and it made
you feel empowered that you stood up and
that you weren't afraid I think there
were stories actually do is they fortify
that which is the culture
the more stories that we have about us
the more that we shared them with
ourselves and with the world at large I
believe the more potent we are as a
people we've been doing this for
hundreds of years you know so this is
just using kind of like the new kind of
accessibility using the new venues to
keep telling the kind of stories that
we've always been telling it's important
to me to find ways to allow others the
opportunity to discover the humanity and
the necessity sadly for full citizenship
for black and brown folks in this
country and a tool and to do that a tool
that I can utilize to do that is
storytelling my coming to writing was
both enacted resistance because how dare
me not be on the page and and a desire
to not have my experience of spending
many years not seeing myself on the page
has happened for another young person I
grew up as spider-man Batman and you had
to kind of like find somebody to
identify with and you know it required
more imagination in a way because then
you could you can relate to qualities
versus kind of like physicality whereas
like you know when I have kids they'll
always have Black Panther and I think
that's like that's a radical position to
always have a hero that looks like them
they don't have to reach when I look
back to that moment of saying I'm black
and I'm proud and and thinking of course
I am you know of course this is the
truth I've known I wanted to be a writer
on my life but it really informed what I
was going to write and how I was going
to write it without apology I mean I was
going to write without apology about
being unapologetically black
unapologetically black I think it's so
important to know your history and tell
your story that's why I think it's great
that we did this
I wish Black History Month though was
incorporated all year yes I was doing it
wasn't just one month the shortest month
by the way 28 days as opposed to 31 that
it was incorporated to all do all of the
year that it just became a thing that
was incorporated in daily lives and in
conversation because the black
experience is fundamentally the American
experience exactly right Alex that's
right that's why roots was the story of
an American family yes and there was a
systematic effort to smash stories to
deny people their roots because without
roots you have no connection and you can
be you can be split up as families and
stories are the key to regaining
identity and that's why it's so
important to see stories and see people
that look like you that represent you
that's why Black Panther is so huge so
we can look forward to Black Panther
number 32 yeah I'll buy tickets to all
the sequels yeah it's it's a very
important conversation that was great
for more of this conversation follow at
CBS this morning on Instagram Twitter
and Facebook you'll see CBS News
correspondent sharing what black history
means to them and you can give us your
own stories using the hashtag my black
history